[Música]
fazia um frio de lascar em são paulo
naquela noite de 7 de junho de 2019 na
avenida paulista os termômetros
anunciavam temperaturas abaixo de 5
graus
ali perto no bairro de perdizes nova um
bairro nobre da capital
jovens de classe média alta bebiam e
conversavam e se divertir
a top estava tão bom que a bebida a cabo
um deles foi até a janela botou braço
lado de fora
sentiu a temperatura disse eu não saio
nem que a vaca tussa um outro teve uma
ideia melhor abril o celular e pedir um
vinho um aplicativo do outro lado da
cidade estava lá
tiago dias 33 anos olhando pra ela pra
tela do celular esperando a próxima
pedido pimba vinho em perdizes
tiago saiu correndo com toda a pressa
enfrentou os 20 os ventos fortes daquela
noite e foi até a porta do prédio de
rico e lá eu avisou a todo mundo que o
pedido tinha chegado e diante da cliente
thiago estendeu a garrafa de vinho de
uma hora pra outra
tiago caiu
ele tinha um corpo enrijecido fortes
dores na cabeça
muito frio e tremia sem conseguir falar
conseguiu dizer ainda uma frase avisa o
rap por favor que estou passando mal
a cliente pegou o celular e avisou rap
que o que seu empregado não estava bem
de uma hora pra outra atendente
respondeu a senhora por favor de baixo
no seu pedido para eu avisar os próximos
clientes que eles vão ter um atraso é na
demanda deles o outro amigo de gopal
samu
nada nada do rap nada do samu
conseguiram contactar a irmã ea mãe do
tiago em pirituba zona norte de são
paulo
atravessaram a cidade por 50 minutos
chegaram lá
thiago ainda tava deitado a mãe
desesperada pediu uber
o carro chega motorista olha vê que
tiago tinha urinado nas calças e diz vou
levar não vai sujar meu carro e você
sabe vai complicar a experiência dos
próximos usuários vai comprometer a
minha nota eo governo vai reembolsar um
amigo vizinho de tiago atravessa a
cidade mais uma vez chega lá pega o
amigo coloca dentro do carro vai ao
hospital mais próximo e o médico dá o
diagnóstico avc
na manhã seguinte à testa morte
encefálica
no outro dia a mãe a irmã ea filha de
seis anos de tiago choram sobre o caixão
o rap ea uber descobre o que aconteceu
pelos jornais
a rap automaticamente libera um
comunicado dizendo que vai se preocupar
nas próximas vezes para dar o melhor
atendimento aos seus parceiros a uber
lavar as mãos diz que não pode obrigar
ninguém a levar alguém a tentar aguentar
até o hospital
nada do samu nada da rapp nada da unha
eu e michel alcoforado antropólogos cuco
confesso que não acredito mais na
economia colaborativa
pra quem não sabe esse jeito novo de
produzir riqueza surgiu nos estados
unidos a partir de 2008 na crise as
pessoas começaram a acreditar que para
produzir dinheiro e capital não
precisava se mais produzir coisas a
gente podia compartilhar como
compartilhar coisas dividir coisas
o sucesso foi tão grande que em 2008 já
movimentavam em torno de 15 bilhões de
dólares ea promessa é que em 2025
movimento em 670 be colaborar
colaborativo
fui ao dicionário colaborar vem do latim
colaborar vem do latim e é uma junção de
duas palavras ficou junto laborar
trabalhar
sentir dor cansaço thiago me fez pensar
uma coisa cansaço pra quem trabalhar com
quem sente dor com quem quem está
sentindo dor nesse sistema há três anos
venho pesquisando o impacto das
plataformas digitais sobre a vida de
todos nós
e posso afirmar sem nenhum medo que a
economia colaborativa nada mais é do que
mais um jeito normatizado de explorar e
precarizar a vida de muita gente
esse jogo é muito precário porque essas
empresas se valem de estratégias muito
claras
primeiro elas não aceitam nenhuma
regulamentação levantam a mãozinha e
desing somos apenas empresas de
tecnologia
o prefeito de são paulo semanas atrás
recebeu um comunicado onde ficava muito
claro aumento do número de mortes de
motoboy na cidade eram 366 um aumento de
18% em relação ao ano anterior
chamou rap chamorro b chamou a log
chamou outras empresas economia
compartilhada e propôs um pacto de
segurança que os parceiros eo b e rap
negaram
eles disseram que não tinha nada a ver
com isso dentro desse jogo ainda fatores
mais complexos
toda vez que tentam tentam regulamentar
a relação dos parceiros com essas
empresas
eles dizem que eles não são seus
empregados não são porque os motores
motoristas de rio verde tem toda a
liberdade de começar a trabalhar quando
quer deixar de trabalhar quando querem
também e dessa forma não configura uma
relação de trabalho leis trabalhistas
foram para o lixo
eles dizem só que seus conseguir seus
parceiros são consumidores
eu digo que eles não são porque você é
consumidor e sabe bem o que determina a
nossa posição nesse lugar
é a nossa capacidade de escolher o que
queremos comprar eo preço que queremos
pagar por elas e se ajusta ou não a
transação está sendo feita
o teu motorista de rubber ele aceita
corrida com o aplicativo apresenta e aí
tentando ainda se desvencilhar
eles dizem que
esses parceiros são empreendedores
falácia empreendedores como empresários
têm capacidade de precificar o seu
serviço e ainda eles têm capacidade
determinada estratégia de entrada no
mercado
o teu a motorista de rubber ele aceita o
aplicativo dá pra ele
os impactos parecem só na vida dessas
pessoas
mas não elas têm impacto na nossa vida
também no presente e no futuro
o que esses aplicativos da economia
colaborativa fazem com a gente primeiro
lugar é desumaniza as pessoas exalando e
recursos humanos ea mudar por completo
nossas relações sociais
só pra ficar aqui no último termo a
gente define um novo jogo mano
saímos de vidas plenas para a vida
existem bairros
você que tem um emprego trabalho num
lugar sabe muito bem que revela que o
contrato de trabalho que você
estabeleceu de 44 horas e de 40 horas
faz com que você venda 8 horas do seu
dia para o empregador
ele faz com você o que ele quiser dentro
das suas funções
esses motoristas de aplicativo ou
motoboy de aplicativo eles vivem um jogo
completamente diferente dizem as
empresas que eles têm liberdade que é
ter liberdade liberdade é você ser pago
somente pelos afazeres ou pelas corridas
que faz com que as empresas não contam é
que essas pessoas pra conseguirem as
corridas que fazem precisam ficar 24
horas à disposição esperando o próximo à
próximo chamado isso são vidas em stand
by
isso são vidas paralisadas estão vindo e
sem futuro e sem vida e sem projeto
isso são vidas precarizados mas você
sabe também que em qualquer evento de
inovação vai aparecer um palestrina
nesse círculo e vai dizer pra você que a
economia compartilhada vai resolver os
nossos problemas ambientais
afinal você não precisará mais comprar
coisas mas compartilhar as coisas que já
existem
certo é verdade mas a gente precisa ter
muita clareza
estamos trocando a exaustão dos recursos
ambientais pela exaustão de recursos
humanos entre em qualquer rubber de uma
grande cidade e pergunte quantas horas
ele precisa trabalhar para ter um
salário ínfimo 12 13 14 e 15 horas sem
qualquer proteção
ah mas eu não uso uber mas quando você
viaja se gosta e certamente de usar web
e que aquele apartamento maravilhoso
moderninho
pois bem na cidade de lisboa em portugal
nos últimos três anos houve um aumento
de 3 mil por cento no número de
apartamentos ofertados na plataforma
daqueles aluguel de longo termo de longo
prazo que restaram aumentaram em média
25% os pobres estão sendo expulsos para
a periferia onde não há lazer onde não
há conhecimento onde não há escolas onde
não há hospitais de qualidade e onde não
há boas ofertas de trabalho
eles estão tendo que se deslocar mais
estão gastando mais e estão perdendo
mais tempo de vida para conseguir o
básico
eles estão vivendo - esse jogo é tão
perverso porque ele se torna uma máquina
de moer gente e o terceiro ponto é muito
importante a gente não esquecer que se
trata na transformação e na
desumanização que esses aplicativos
fazem com a gente
o as experiências humanas
elas são transformadas em experiências
de usuário e usuário não tem nome não
tem sobrenome não tem gosto não tem
religião não tem partido político e não
têm contradições ele é igual aqueles
bonequinhos do mario bros no mario bros
no teu jogo de nintendo nos anos 90 que
só tinha um caminho para trilhar e o
objetivo final a ser alcançado
esse processo todo faz com que a gente
transforme pessoas em avatares andando
dentro dos nossos celulares
eu tenho certeza que você tem prazer de
ficar acompanhando o deslocamento do seu
bebê por dentro do seu aplicativo
ali não tem só um avatar ali tem gente
foi pensando só em avatares que é
atendente do rápido não se preocupou com
thiago foi pensamos só em avatares que
que a gente tem que
você por exemplo numa noite de chuva
torrencial não tem pena de pedir uma
pizza em casa no e também pelo mesmo
motivo quando você está com preguiça de
à venda mais próxima
você não pensa duas vezes e impedir
alguém pra entregar pra você tem gente
ali por trás e além disso há um ponto
mais importante o que nos define como
seres humanos é a nossa capacidade de
escolha de reflexão os aplicativos nos
resumem aos jogos de 5 ou não há jogos
de algoritmos binários baseados inverno
um a jogos de pretos e brancos ea gente
e 50 torres de sisa para trazer um clima
mais leve a equipe nesse momento
pensando bem o ponto que a gente vê é
que esse processo de desumanização faz
com que nós escolhemos das pessoas e
pensamos sempre que são os aplicativos
que entrega
não não são eu enquanto consumidor
não quero ser tratado como aplicamos
como algoritmo como o código e também
não quero que as pessoas que me serve
sejam tratadas como uma seqüência de
números
a gente é muito mais complexo do que
isso eu sou michel cidadão carioca
cidadão carioca que mora em são paulo
cidadão do brasil e cidadão do mundo
em tempos em que consumir cidadania tão
diretamente relacionados nós temos o
papel fundamental de cobrar dessas
empresas que lembrem disso porque
sabemos que tem muita gente ganhando
pouco e uma meia dúzia ganhando muito
dinheiro tem gente por trás do
aplicativo tem gente quando você pede
uma pizza e ela chega ainda cá em casa é
e você fala que maravilha que entrega
esse serviço tem gente ali podia ser o
teatro tem gente quando você paga 5
reais de uma corrida de hubei de longa
distância e você comemora os seus olha
que barato
são famílias precarizados e tem gente
quando você perde o refrigerante só
porque está com preguiça de botar o
sapato e até a esquina aplicativo é bom
mas tem gente é muito melhor ea gente
não pode esquecer disso
eu peço que vocês não esqueça
que caso contrário a tal da colaboração
vai nos matar
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]